soir olivier delorme alors cette visite
en turquie de charles michel et vendeurs
ursula von der leyen à ce qu'elles
étaient indispensables c'était urgent de
renouer le dialogue a certainement pas
on donne là un très mauvais signal
erdogan qui n'a fait aucune concession
sur aucun dossier en allant chez lui
pour en quelque sorte renouer un
dialogue qui n'a jamais été rompu et
alors que on a pris des sanctions qui
n'en sont pas alors que la turquie
multiplie les provocations à l'égard de
l'union européenne et notamment à
l'égard de deux de ses membres chypre et
la grèce
tout au long de l'été il n'y a eu aucune
détente
il n'y a eu aucun progrès dans l'est
dans les discussions gréco-turque kyo
qui ont repris il il n'y a eu aucune
concession d'erdogan sur les droits de
l'homme
au contraire il a lancé une procédure
d'interdiction du parti du seul parti en
réalité qui est pour une véritable
démocratie en turquie et est de surcroît
aujourd'hui erdogan enfin des personnes
de la de l'entourage de rigueur
d'ailleurs dogan parle de revoir la
course ou montreux sur la circulation
dans les détroits
donc je dirais que c'est une fois de
plus une erreur d'analysé stratégique de
l'union européenne d'aller à canossa
danser dans ces conditions là c'est
aussi un échec de la position soutenue
par emmanuel macron la position de
fermeté envers la turquie
écoutez en tout cas emmanuel macron a
envoyé des des forces et notamment le
groupe aéronaval français
le porte avions charles de gaulle qui se
trouve aujourd'hui en méditerranée
orientale doc la france a une position
de de soutien à la grèce et à chypre
dans la défense de leur souveraineté et
et du droit international puisque la
turquie viol dans cette affaire le droit
de la mer et les conventions du droit de
la mer donc donc macron à une position
qui est une position qui est une
position logique mais il se heurte à une
allemagne qui exercent des pressions
insensé sur l'union européenne pour
empêcher toute sanction à l'égard de la
turquie et on va aujourd'hui problème
malheureusement
de plus vous a alors alors que vous ne
m'entendez plus les liaisons heureuses
un petit peu perdues monsieur de leur
valeur et c'est essayer de reprendre
votre propos vous avez perdu quelques
secondes malheureusement je disais qu'un
alors où la turquie recommence à
utiliser larmes des migrants en faisant
débarquer de nouveaux de nouveaux
migrants dans les îles grecques
c'est c'est très contre-productif de la
part de l'union européenne poussée par
l'allemagne sur laquelle l'allemagne
exerce des pressions insensé en faveur
de la turquie aujourd'hui d'aller
négocier et d'aller négocier notamment
d'après ce qu'on nous dit de nouvelle
aide financière à la turquie alors que
la turquie est effectivement dans une
situation financière extrêmement
problématique puisque la livre et et ans
est en chute libre depuis le dernier
changement le quatrième en quatre ans de
gouverneur de la banque centrale par air
de gagne de manière complètement
erratiques donc
monnet turque est en chute libre et on
va aller proposer à erdogan sans aucune
contrepartie une aide financière et
éditons des facilités des facilités pour
accorder des visas ou tueur que dans
l'union européenne
donc si vous laissez des roms en europe
at elle le choix puisque l'on sait
ankara exerce une forme de chantage sur
la question migratoire
écoutez on n'a jamais on n'a jamais on
n'a jamais arrêté
les jours ce qu'ils font des coups de
force en en allant de négocier avec eux
c'est à dire qu'aujourd'hui l'union
européenne devrait devrait on compte
tout au contraire fixer des lignes
rouges précise ar dogan et faire savoir
à erdogan que il n'a pas le droit
d'utiliser cette arme des migrants et
non pas essayer et n'ont pas cédé à
chaque fois à son chantage
donc si vous voulez la question
aujourd'hui c'est que l'on devrait avoir
à l'égard de d'ankara une politique de
fermeté et que au contraire sous la
pression de l'allemagne
on a une politique de faiblesse alors il
ya quand même ce rappel à l'ordre sur
les droits humains s'atomise son
conditions lé symbole et pour vous
[Musique]
écouter tout ça tout ça et tout ça est
totalement théorie puisque derrière les
sanctions kaka le cas adopter l'union
européenne à reculons alors que chypre
et la grèce en demande et la france
demandent de réelles sanctions depuis
des mois madame merkel a mis son véto à
à toute véritable sanction j'ajouterai
madame merkel et l'espagne qui est gavé
dont les banques sont très engagés dans
la bataille était turc et qui a
aujourd'hui très peur que la turquie
fasse défaut voilà donc si vous voulez
on a une fois de plus à l'intérieur de
l'union européenne des intérêts
divergents qui font que la position
européenne est totalement incohérente et
que on va caresser dans le sens du poil
quelqu'un qui agresse depuis des mois et
des mois de deux états membres de
l'union européenne
donc si vous venez tout ça est
absolument à incohérent et montre une
fois de plus qu'on n'ait pas plus forts
à 27 dans l'union européenne
parce qu'à 27 on a des on a des intérêts
divergents et que la position commune
est toujours le plus petit dénominateur
commun entre les vingt-sept et on ne
fait pas une politique vis-à-vis de
quelqu'un qui agit de manière cynique et
avec des coups de force on ne fait pas
de politique
avec un plus petit dénominateur commun
merci beaucoup olivier delorme historien
et écrivain auteur de la grèce et des
balkans d'avoir été avec nous en direct
sur rt france